le premier procès pour crime de guerre
en ukraine depuis l'invasion russe s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à un militaire russe
de 21 ans accusé d'avoir tué dans la rue
avec une kalachnikov un civils non armés
on retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant gulliver craag à kiev
l'ukraine a donc ouvert son premier
procès pour crimes de guerre mais
l'audience est ajournée pourquoi
je pense que c'est une question
procédurale il fallait fixer certains
aspects de caumont la procédure allait
se dérouler et donc la prochaine
audience ou si vous voulez la première
vraie audience où on entendra les
arguments de la défense ce sera pour
mercredi prochain le 18 mai l'avocat de
la défense tout comme le défendent ont
été présents aujourd'hui l'avocat de la
défense s'est exprimé assez longuement
aux journalistes concernant la procédure
c'est un avocat qui a été nommé par
l'état ukrainien je pense que il est
important pour l'ukraine de montrer que
ce procès qui est jugé dans un cour de
justice ordinaire juste de la justice
ordinaire criminels ils n'ont pas des
tribunal spécial pour les militaires un
nid pour les crimes de guerre donc c'est
la première fois que quelqu'un est jugé
pour crimes de guerre dans un tribunal
spécial l ukraine voulait bien montrer
que toutes les procédures sont
respectées qu'on avocat de la défense
est nommé il a expliqué que ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il va dire quels sont les
arguments de la défense mais que cela
pourrait être que l'accusé nie tout
simplement les faits dit que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre par exemple qui a
commis ce crime là ou bien qu' il dise
qu'il a agi sous les ordres de ses
supérieurs
les avocats de la prostitution telle
accusation eux ont dit que si une plaie
doigt que ils agissaient sous des ordres
c'est quelque chose qui doit être prise
en compte mais ne doit pas non plus
forcément aboutir à ce qu'ils soient
rendus non coupable ça ne la bezole pas
de toute responsabilité
le défendent on était là on a tous bien
vu qu'il est très jeune c'est un soldat
russe de 21 ans qui est en captivité
ukrainienne et c'est le premier procès
d'une série d'autres à venir
oui je disais ce soldat là il est dans
les mains des ukrainiens il y en a au
moins deux autres qui seront jugés je
pense assez rapidement parce que le
crâne a envie de procéder très
rapidement avec les cas avec lesquels
elle peut procéder mais bien sûr la
majorité des soldats russes qui sont
accusés de ces crimes ne sont pas aux
mains des ukrainiens ils sont
probablement en russie ou bien peut-être
encore sur les fronts où les batailles
font encore rage dans l'est et dans le
sud de l'ukraine donc il y aura
peut-être des procès qui seront faits in
absentia est ce qu'il est particulier
aussi dans ce cas c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de témoins il y avait d'autres
gens dans ce village où ce villageois de
68 ans a été tuée et qu'ils ont vu et
qui ont raconté pour des crimes qui ont
été commis à des endroits comme here pin
ou du cha ou des combats faisait encore
rage entre les russes et les ukrainiens
il y avait des tirs d'artillerie un peu
de partout il est beaucoup moins de
témoin il est très difficile de trouver
des témoins je parlais un policier haïr
pin ce matin qui disait justement qu'il
est tellement difficile de trouver des
témoins parce que tout simplement la
plupart de la population de ces endroits
là étaient cachés dans les sous sols
surtout au moment où il y avait les où
il y avait les combats donc même si les
corps ont été trouvés avec des blessures
de balle il ya très peu de gens qui ont
vu les crimes être commises merci
beaucoup d'univers craque